think in a reasonable backlash to say
the body shaming and the stigmatization
of mental health in the decades past
there has been now perhaps an over
correction in the way that we view
self-love rather than just focusing on
it and being kinder to ourselves and
more forgiving of ourselves there does
seem to be quite a lot of people out
there a lot of individuals a lot of
corporates a lot of messaging that now
it's all about you
um and actually if you start just
seeking out ways to be a bit nicer to
yourself you can easily become quite
exhausted you have to love yourself
apparently all the time without fail no
excuses no questions and I write this
week that I actually think that that
kind of self-focus not only is it a bit
narcissistic but it can really just
drive you to misery